I think it's important to educate as
many kids as possible in this part of
the world about science and especially
girls because we do not have enough
scientists who are women
[Music]
ever look through one of these in parts
of Africa chances are most likely know
this stargazer wanted to change that my
name is Susan Marie Bona I'm an
astronomer I think Africa needs for
scientists and especially scientist
Smith stain the continent because that
way will create scientific solutions to
our problems so how do you get more
young Africans to be scientists get them
to become stargazers first but houston
we might have a problem telescopes are
limited in kind of very limited in Kenya
so how do you get around that I travel
in telescope ah and who's he to my
husband
he is also an astronomer the idea of the
traveling telescope was for us to make
it easy for people to look to the
telescope by us going to the people and
once it's all packed Susan and Chu
loaded up and off they go it's no easy
task but they've reached 40,000 students
in the last three years like these girls
we do viewings both during the day and
at night when you get to a venue the
kids see us inside the telescope is that
yeah it's so nice to see the reaction
the moon looks brighter and bigger cuz
it's closer to us okay and that's called
as super moon the main goal of the
traveling telescope is to get as many
young people as possible interested in
science I want to be an engineer I saw
the moon for the first time through a
telescope so amazing it's cool I wanna
learn more about the moon and I would
like to go to space awesome
it makes you feel really nice to have
young people think of science
I feel that science is the way will you
know develop and develop in a
sustainable way
you
[Music]